هذا القمر ، إنها ناجية من الحرب ،
نعم إنها مريضة ، إنها في حالة سيئة ،
إنها مصابة بالجفاف ،
حسنًا ،
إنها خائفة من أنها تعاني من الكثير من المشاكل ،
التهاب البنكرياس ، وربما الديدان ، ولديها أيضًا
ورم يجب إزالته ولكن على
الأقل تم إنقاذها من ملجأ
في  أوكرانيا بعد أن بدأت الحرب لم تكن
عدوانية أو سمحت لك فقط بفعل
ما تحتاجه لتفعله ، فلا بأس يا
حبيبتي
هذا الطبيب البيطري يجب أن يخدع ويدفع
لمعرفة مدى مرضها حقًا
كل شيء في أذن هذا الكلب شمع الأوساخ
إيمان يجب علينا تنظيفه
هذا هو
نفسه
لمدة
سبعة أيام
وسبعة أيام ، يجب عليك الاستمرار في القيام
بذلك ، حيث يعامل الموظفون في مؤسسة أوتا
هذه الكلاب على أنها ملكهم ،
إنه مأوى للحيوانات لا تقتل في
بولندا ، حيث يتم رعاية مئات
الحيوانات من أوكرانيا التي مزقتها الحرب.
لم ينموا كثيرًا منذ
بدء الحرب في أوكرانيا المجاورة ، فهم
على بعد أميال قليلة من الحدود الأوكرانية البولندية
، وكان الموظفون يقودون سياراتهم إلى
أوكرانيا التي مزقتها الحرب لإنقاذ trucklo  إعلانات عن
حيوانات مأوى وحيوانات أليفة لا يستطيع الناس
حملها عبر الحدود في غرفة أخرى
المزيد من الحيوانات قصص حرب مختلفة
هذه
ساشا وهي من أوكرانيا
ماعز صغير تم إحضاره من أوكرانيا
بأرجل تحتاج إلى إصلاح
طفل نعسان ساشا طفل حديث الولادة يبلغ من العمر
سبعة أعوام فقط  أيام من العمر ، يمكنك معرفة ذلك لأنه
يحاول أن يرضع على شحمة أذني
عندما لا يخرج الحليب
يقول الأطباء إنه لولا الرعاية التي حصل عليها
هنا لكان قد مات جوعاً إذا
تُركت وحدها في أوكرانيا كانت ستموت
إذا لم تكن هنا بشكل أساسي
أو سيموت سيموت إذا
لم يكن سيموت ابن
مؤسس مؤسسة آدم يخبرنا أن ساشا قد
أنزلتها امرأة هنا بعد أن
هربت من أوكرانيا إلى بولندا ولكن لم
يكن لديها مكان لتأخذه لكنها تركت
تعليمات واحدة قالت إنها  سيعود لإحضاره إلى
أنه يحبه ، إنه عائلته ،
هذه مجرد قصتين عن حرب الحيوانات
يصل المئات والمزيد كل أسبوع
، وفي كل أسبوع تحصل هذه الحيوانات على
رعاية من الدرجة الأولى للموظفين هنا
لاجئي الحرب هؤلاء.  هـ - لا تقل أهمية
العناية عن الإنسان عنك